Puppis they're the furry friends we take
for granted but how does having one
affect us my name is Meg Olmert and I'm
the author of made for each other the
biology of the human animal bond our
journey with dogs began about 45,000
years ago according to the latest
archaeological evidence it proceeded
many hundreds of thousands of years with
a more casual and perhaps distant
pragmatic relationship with wolves as
well but about 45,000 years ago we start
to see the bones change and indications
that a dog's are certainly living with
us and that living with us appears to
have had certain effects on their
biology and their physiology that is
what enabled them to become our best
friends how does this relationship work
there is a feedback system that both
neurochemically and psychologically and
behaviorally that that sets up between
you and your pet and how good you are to
your pet is often exactly reflected back
although what I would say is they tend
to be wildly generous more generous than
we are
so that is why you know they'll be
wagging their tail you know thrilled to
see you when you come home or if it's a
cat it's purring and you may be very
distracted but they aren't you are the
greatest thing they ever saw if you've
developed this relationship if you've
earned it you have a different
relationship with your own pet versus
your even your neighbors pet because
it's that's your closer family it's a
different kind of bond and when they do
fMRI studies just like a mother will
have a certain brain regions light up
very strongly in the dopamine and
oxytocin rich areas when they look at a
picture of their baby versus just
another infant when you look at a
picture of your dog versus another dog
you see the same thing if you love dogs
you're going to get this
ward it to a degree whether you are
looking at your dog or not do therapy
dogs work well they certainly can dogs
can do amazing things with our program
warrior canine connection we work with
servicemembers and veterans with
post-traumatic stress disorder we have
the patients who say this dog is better
than any drug I ever took I didn't sleep
for five years until this dog slept next
to me what happens to your body when
you're with your dog your heart rate
comes down your blood pressure comes
down your heart rate variability which
is the ability of the heart to duck and
dive and respond to stress improves you
release oxytocin the opioids adrenaline
and the serotonin so all of these great
reward chemicals and anti stress
chemicals can be released in both you
and the pet what is oxytocin oxytocin is
a very ancient chemical it's in all
social mammals there's variations on it
that you find in birds and in Turtles
and in worms and it most effectively is
known for releasing breast milk and
creating labor contractions that's what
it was first known for so in in a sense
it is the quintessential mad million
hormone since live birth and production
of breast milk identifies us as mammals
and mammary glands etc about 25 years
ago they discovered that besides the
oxytocin receptors and cells in the body
that are producing oxytocin and the
breast and the uterus lo and behold it's
produced throughout the brain and in all
the areas that control behavior and
emotion so what was it doing there and
what they discovered was that it was
talking to other classic brain
neurotransmitters such as serotonin and
dopamine and adrenaline and the opioid
system and it was setting up by doing
that this perfect mental physiologic
state of calm
it is the most powerful drive and it
creates the bond that lasts a lifetime
that's how strong it is